네. 안녕하세요.
빌사남매노크 김요수입니다. 제가 오늘
좀 설명드릴 거는 최근에 우리나라 좀
정치 이슈도 되게 많고 트럼프
대통령이 당선된 다음에 그 해외
정치에 대한 불안감도 되게 커지고
제가 최근에 두바이 다녀오면서 앞으로
한국 부동산은 좀 어떻게 될 거 같냐
뭐 이런 질문들을 좀 많이 봤습니다.
그래서 한국부동산에 대한 내용과 제가
해외 부동산을 보면서 느꼈던 점들을
여러분들한테 어 설명드리도록
하겠습니다. 어 우선 지금 우리나라
부동산은 지금 좀 상황이 매우 안
좋은 거 같아요. 그래서 지금 뭐
최근에도 GDP가 마이너스 성장률을
기억했고 지금 기준 금리가 뭐
2.75긴 하지만 실질적인 내수
경기는 그렇게 좋지 않습니다. 지금
심리도 많이 위축되고 뭐 자영업자분들
같은 경우에는 작년 기준으로 거의
100만 명이 가까울 정도로 폐업에
이르렀는데 그거와 반대로 지금
자산가들 비율은 높아지고 있어요.
그래서 진짜 제가 요즘 많이 체감하는
거지만 어 양극화가 되게 심해지고
있습니다. 우리나라 같은 경우에는
앞으로 초고령화 사회가 이미
접어들었어요. 지금 뭐 거의 65세
이상 인구가 20% 정도 됩니다.
2032년도에는 거의 30% 가까이
돼요. 이미 고령화가 돼서 지금 인구
그래프가 이렇게 돼 있습니다. 그래서
지금 밑에 있는 청년층들은 거의 없고
이제 노인들이 많아지는 그런 시대에
곧 접어들었어요. 그래서 어떻게 보면
생산 가능 인구가 계속 줄어들고
있습니다. 출생자 수도 계속 줄어들고
있고 앞으로 제가 봤을 때는
저성장을 계속 좀 오랫동안 유지할 거
같아요. 뭐 70년도 80년도에 막
그때 막 막 이렇게 활기웠던 GDP도
올라가고 성장률이 높았던 그런 시대와
다르게 그래프가 예전에 이제 일했다면
지금은 제가 봤을 때 이렇게 갈 거
같습니다. 아주 오랫동안. 그래서
지금 여러분들이 만약에 부동산 투자를
하신다라고 하면은 제 개인적인
생각에는 확실한 거만 이제 앞으로
오를 거 같아요. 자산가는 계속
많아졌기 때문에 자산가들이 좋아할
만한 부동산 그런 거 위주로 가격이
좀 오를 것 같습니다. 그리고 제가
두바이에 가면서 좀 느꼈던 점이
두바이는 해외 자금이 들어올 수 있게
다 열어 놨어요. 그래서 일정 금액
이상 투자하면 골든 비자도 나오고
누구나 다 이제 창업을 쉽게 할 수
있게 그렇게 해 놨는데 지금 우리나라
같은 경우에는 그런게 좀 되게
제한적입니다. 그리고 제가 인성
깊뻤던 거 중에 하나가 거기 현재에
계신 분한테 얘기를 좀 들었는데
한국에 대한 호기심이 되게 많았어요.
근데 한국에서 이렇게 비자 얻기가
쉽지 않나 봐요. 특히 이제 아랍
쪽에 계신 분들, 중동에 계신 분들은
이렇게 비자가 좀 잘 안 나온다
그러더라고요. 그리고 지금 두바이
같은 경우에는 이렇게 젊은 층들이
계속 많아지고 있고 그러다 보니까
이제 생산 가능 인구도 되게 많아지고
외국인이 거의 90%거든요. 네.
그리고 자본도 많다 보니까 진짜
부동산 개발도 되게 붐이 이뤄지는
반명이네. 우리나라는 사실 기름 한
방울 안 나잖아요. 다 이제 수출로
먹고 사는 나라인데 최근에 뭐 관세
이슈라든지 이런게 너무 발생되다
보니까 우리나라가 점점 좀 어려워지고
있는 거 같습니다. 그리고 세금 같은
경우에도 두바이는 법인세 9%
제외하고는 세금이 없어요. 뭐
소득세도 없고 양도 소득세도 없고
지금 우리나라 같은 경우에는 세율이
되게 높잖아요. 그래서 뭐 10억
초과 같은 경우에는 49.5% 5%
세금을 내고 법인세도 지금 20%
대이기도 하고 그 제가 봤을 땐
앞으로 세금이 더 높아질 것
같거든요. 저 처음 일할 때까지만
해도 양도소득 세율이 40%까진
아니었거든요. 근데 이게 더 줄어들
가능성은 제가 봤을 땐 없어
보입니다. 근데 그거와 반해서 지금
두바이는 세금 혜택이나 이런게 너무
좋기 때문에 많은 자금들이 다
그쪽으로 몰리고 있어요. 근데
우리나라 같은 경우에는이 상속
증여세가 너무 커요. 이게 지금
몇십년 전에 만든 건데 이게 진짜
말도 안 되게 큽니다. 기업을 일단
성공시키는 것도 쉽지 않고 그리고
기업을 운영하면서 세금을 정상적으로
다 나빠했는데도 불구하고 상속이
되거나 할 때 세금 부담이 엄청
크거든요. 그래서 세금을 못 내서
회사가 망하는 경우도 받고 부동산을
매각하는 경우가 태반이거든요.
우리나라 그 상속이랑 증여세율은 저는
반드시 손을 봐야 된다라는 사람 중에
한 명이에요. 두바이 같은 경우에는
상속 증여세가 없습니다. 그리고 지금
우리나라 부동산 가격이 많이
올랐잖아요. 근데 그 구간이 저는 좀
더 높아져야 된다라고 생각하거든요.
그래서 웬만한 지금 서울시에 부동산
가지고 계신 분들은 다 상속 증여세가
문제가 될 수 있습니다. 예전에 진짜
몇십년 전에 기준으로 만들었던이 상속
증여세는 수정을 해야 되지 않나?
네. 이렇게 생각을 하고 있습니다.
우리 자산가들이 우리나라를 많이 좀
떠나고 있습니다. 슬픈 얘긴데
데이터를 좀 보면은 우리나라가
4위인가 그래요. 자산가들이 이미
가는 것 중에 1위가 중국이고 뭐
2위가 인도고 3위가 기억이 안
나는데 4위가 우리나라입니다. 그래서
인구수 대비해서는 자산가들이 많이 좀
우리나라를 떠나고 있어요. 그래서
결론을 좀 말씀드리면 우리나라
부동산은 앞으로 더 양극화가 심해질
것 같다. 그리고 우리나라 특성상
예전 부자들도 그렇고 기존 부자들도
그렇고 다 부동산으로 축척을 했기
때문에 부동산에 대한 호감도 투자에
대한 그런 인식이 되게 좋아서 다른
나라와 비교해서는 확실히 투자 가치가
있긴 하는데 이제 앞으로 더
오르는데만 오를 거다. 뭐 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같고. 그리고 이제
상업 같은 경우에는 기존에는 국내
사람들도 많고 어 이렇게 상권을
이용할 사람들이 많아서 진짜 뭐
대학가 상권이라든지 막 여러 상건들이
다 활발해졌었는데 이제 앞으로 더
줄어들 겁니다. 외국인 관광객들이
오지않은 상권은 더 죽을 거 같아요.
그래서 앞으로 상권을 볼 때 국내
사람뿐만 아니라 외국인 상권까지
흡수를 해야지 그 상권이
살아남는다라고 생각을 합니다. 그리고
이제 상권 내에서도 양극화가 되게
심해질 거 같아요. 뭐 예를 들어서
성수동 같은 경우에는 그 인근에 있는
상권을 다 빨아들였어요. 상권에 대한
양극화도 더 심해질 거다. 네.
이렇게 저는 생각을 합니다. 그래서
오늘 좀 제 개인적인 얘기를 좀
드렸는데 지금 위기긴 하지만 기존에
이렇게 유명했던 분들이 한국의 위상을
되게 높여 줘서 저는 이제 해외
시장에 뭔가 진출할 만한 그런 기회가
저는 왔다라고 생각을 합니다. 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요. 빌딩은
역시 빌산업.